[موسيقى]
ان تجوب العالم على متن سفينه دون ان
تتحرك امر ليس بغريب فالرحله علمتني سفينه
الشعار الامل ليست بحريه لكنها ثقافيه
بنتياز الاف الكتب على متنها في مكتبه
عائمه استحقت اجمل استقبال
تبدا الرحله بين اكثر من خمسه الاف كتاب
تتنوع ما بين العلوم والثقافه والادب
المئات من الحضور اتاحت لهم هذه المكتبه
العائمه فرصه الغوص في اعماق الحضارات
والثقافات في مكتبه غير تقليديه رست في
خليج العقبه وارثت معها معظم حضرات الشعوب
في كتب نامل بان يصل لعدد صور هذه السفينه
الى 60,000 زائر خلال وجودها في العشرين
يوم القادمين لوحات فنيه مميزه سيتم فيها
تبادل للثقافات وتبادل للخبرات خلال
وجودها ايضا كما نعلم بانه المكتبه هي همم
اهل المعرفه واصلا المعرفه مما سيزيد فرصه
التعرف والتواصل والحوار بين كثير من
الثقافات 400 متطوع استقلو هذه السفينه
للعمل في اكبر مكتبه عامه هدفها الترويج
للقراءه واعاده الحياه للكتب ببيعها
باسعار رمزي ان حاجه رغبه كثيري هذا
التنوع يعني بتلاقي في مجال لكل الناس انا
بحب الطبخ بروح للطبخ واللي بحب اللغات
بيروح اللغات كتب الاطفال كثير متنوعه
يعني في اشياء كثير جميله
ايام وتبحر من جديد بعد زيارتها لاكثر من
400 و80 من الان في 150 دوله كاشفه عن
اسرار مئات الكتب وفاتحه المجال للغوص في
الاف الصفحات والسطور لصباح العربيه عماد
العضائله مدينه العقبه